the number one rule in fighting there's
no suing in fighting here's the good
news if you figure all that out you get
through this storm that you're dealing
with and you head kick viente luk you
get on that mic and you rip the hottest
freaking promo calling out Shan
Strickland and Leon Edwards Sean
Strickland come get some UFC 300 Leon
Edwards yeah I did get kicked out of the
gym big deal I'm glad I got kicked out I
see get UFC 307 double champ who wants
it mic drop merch money different
narrative what there's so much
opportunity here but you wasted it you
threatened
lawsuit number one rule in prize
fighting you don't Sue each other I
can't emphasize enough second a fight
club we don't shoot each other again
your weapons are these and those